okay we've surpassed 6,000 viewers and
listeners on the David Pakman show
subreddit great place to discuss
politics at david pakman.com slash read
it if you're worried about trolling
something very very common on the reddit
platform we have moderators the
moderators have been fully deputized to
evaluate whether people are trolling are
posting 20 things a day or whatever i
got rolling you were banned from our
reddit yeah for patrolling originally so
you won't be seeing pad on there okay a
few interesting discussions from the
reddit discussion forum number one i
can't take any more politics I've had
enough I'm checking out I'm done I can't
take any more Trump I've had my fill of
conservatism and I'm absolutely sick of
America I love your show David but I
can't handle any more politics for the
foreseeable future I'm checking out into
the land of music and drugs and video
games someone wake me up when this
effing disaster of a presidency is over
you know I I sympathize I mean we have
we've heard this from viewers before
that they are sort of at a limit when it
comes to dealing with the horrible
realities of politics that are going on
and I congratulate you for making that
call and I'll see you on the other side
my friend I reach that limit too
sometimes and I have to check out for a
week or two weeks yeah but I always come
back to it yeah and what's craziest Pat
has checked out for two-week periods
while we're doing the show
that's what's wild people will be
shocked to hear that sometimes for ten
shows in a row Pat will be here but
completely checked out from bottom just
on autopilot also from the David Pakman
show subreddit televangelist jim bakker
calls his missouri cabins the safest
spot for the apocalypse
yeah no surprise the jim bakker always
has something to sell you the safest
thing for food supply during the
upcoming apocalypse is bonus buckets
with 3000 pounds of mashed potatoes the
safest place to be during the upcoming
apocalypse is going to be the cabins
that he can sell you access to this guy
is a grifter of the highest order
and I mean it's not he has it he doesn't
answer for everything you just have to
be ready to pay him for it
we haven't done a Jim Baker story in a
while even though there's plenty of
material there we're gonna have to
revisit that soon I do want to get the
Jim Baker at some point yeah another
discussion from the David Pakman show
subreddit someone posting a screenshot
of the David Pakman show on DirecTV
saying I'm a regular viewer since 2016
and I just watched the David Pakman show
on DirecTV for the first time this is
perhaps the first time I've seen the
David Pakman show
not on my phone I don't know why but
this feels out of the norm or what I'm
used to yeah a lot of people who watch
us online don't know that we are the 10
p.m. show Monday through Friday on both
DirecTV and Dish Network free speech TV
channel and that's it's a really
exciting thing I don't know what else
does that are you telling me that we're
on Direct TV right now then Pat didn't
even know Pat's been producing the show
for a year and a half he has no idea
that were on free speech TV every day
and lastly from our subreddit David
Pakman when a person calls your show and
makes a statement and then pauses for a
long time they're waiting for you to
verify enhance or otherwise add
something to what they said sometimes
they just want a statement from you
without a question and assurance on
their thoughts is that okay
I guess what they're referring to is
that sometimes people will call in and
ramble during live calls and I will say
is there a question and I am okay with
people calling in sort of for
verification about an idea but I think I
can usually tell when people are doing
that like sometimes there's just
rambling with not even any kind of
defined end point or way for me to
comment and I think it's perfectly
respectable for me to say is there a
particular question that you have for me
today it's not always rambling though
sometimes it's just one or two sentences
and then a long pause yeah so maybe then
they're waiting for some validation or
some feedback for you but I just think
that people get nervous and perhaps lose
their train of thought yeah and I think
even if that's the case it's okay for me
to sort of prompt them by saying okay
you know I think I understand your
perspective is there something in
particular that I that I can answer for
you but it's become very clear that
there's a contingent in our audience
that will never be happy with how I
manage the
calls because if I either people said
David you let people ramble for too long
you got to be like Tom Hart Tom Hartman
and get more quickly to what the
question is so I try to do that and then
people say other people they say David
you're being rude and you're not you're
not being polite enough and just
allowing people to express the review so
I think no matter what somebody will
always be unhappy with live calls david
pakman.com slash read it join the
discussion